we're at capacity tonight here at the
opulent Tostitos Center
50,000 fans are ready to binge drink for
a couple of hours I tell you what I
can't wait
hot I've grilled mad [ __ ] Sarika then
I'm grown man Bob descends here
that's right Bob and we have both made
careers watching adult men play a simple
child's game all well being paid more
than the president okay chick and it
seems as though the millionaires are
ready to play their game so we can stop
stalling with the mindless Chad the ride
has been the ball of the play and the
alleged rapist passes the big orange
ball to the sweaty legal giant easily
puts the ball into the basket making it
look easy which victory seven feet tall
it is he made about $8,000 while he was
doing now the power Falcons are bringing
the ball to play the high school dropout
inbounds to the convicted spousal abuse
er he slashes through all of the drug
addict stops the ball to the genetic
freak boom quack the lack of cue points
don't ask your black ass bingo term
scams just saying words and start with
this gray pub
you
you